okay so this presentation is going to be
on angiosperms and so let's just get
into it because it's kind of a longer
presentation than normal
so the other day we introduced seed
producing vascular plants and we the
other day we focused on gymnosperms for
instance the example we focused on work
ona firs trees that reproduce with cones
well today we're gonna focus on the
other category of seed producing
vascular plants that would be
angiosperms angiosperms is the name of
the plants that produce flowers and
flowers is simply the reproductive
structure it's what they use to
reproduce and and to pass on their genes
to the next generation and so the
purpose of a flower well now don't well
it's to reproduce but the purpose of a
flower the the colors the fragrance is
to attract a pollinator some pollinators
can be birds some pollinators can be
insects and and so that's really the
true purpose of of what the flower
structure is is to attract a pollinator
and eventually when the when pollination
occurs and then eventually a sperm and
egg fertilized and a zygote is created
eventually we'll talk about how a fruit
forms so all flowers eventually produce
a fruit inside of the fruit you'll find
the seeds and this is how angiosperms
get their name angiosperm is I think
Latin for basically means that the seeds
are covered in this case they're covered
with the fruit so we mentioned that the
big difference between this group 3 the
seed producing vascular plants the
difference between them and ferns is
that they are seed producing so they
produce seeds the seeds grow inside of
the fruit the seeds are covered by the
fruit that again that's literally what
angiosperms means if the seeds are
covered and as we mentioned the other
day inside the seed you find a couple
items you find the actual embryo and you
find a food storage we'll talk more
about that food storage as these notes
go on but that embryo will feed off of
the food storage until a seed cracks
open and it's little tiny baby Embree
leaf is able to do photosynthesis for
the first time
you
and so we mentioned that not only is the
purpose of the flower to to attract a
pollinator but then the flower turns
into a fruit and inside of the fruit you
find the seeds
well the seeds need to be dispersed and
so often the seeds are brightly colored
to attract some sort of animal in here
in the picture we have brightly colored
red berries brightly colored yellow
bananas and so these fruits are being
consumed and what we'll see is that the
seeds will pass through the animal's
digestive system in a moment you're
gonna find a rather silly animation of a
horse kind of looks like the horse is
doing a handstand to eat this Apple and
here it goes so the horse will eat the
apple and eventually the horse will
gallop away and eventually the horse
will stop running and now 1012 hours may
go by and the horse takes a poop and in
that pile of poo are seeds the seeds
have survived passage through the
digestive system the acids of the
stomach don't destroy the seeds the
fruit is digested yes but not the seeds
the seeds can be pooped out into a big
pile of fertilizer that poop has
leftover nutrients in it and so those
seeds have a great start to growing the
benefit of being dispersed like this
imagine if the seed simply fell straight
down from the parent tree the parent
tree would hog all the nutrients the
parent tree would block all the sunlight
so by being dispersed like this it gives
the seeds of better chance it doesn't
guarantee that they're gonna grow but it
gives the seeds a better chance to grow
here we have a few pictures of tip
droppings to be honest these are just a
bird droppings on the left with seeds
and fox droppings on the right and so in
the fox droppings you can see seeds and
so this is one way that seeds are
dispersed
you
when we talk about angiosperms there's
two big broad categories of angiosperms
and you can see from the picture the two
BRIC big broad categories are called
monocot and dicot well they both have
the suffix cut Co T in them and that's
in reference to the fact that
angiosperms grow what's called a cattle
eaten as an embryo they either have one
embryonic leaf and if they do we call
that that we call them a monocot or as
an embryo they'll have two leaves and we
call them a dicot so this is our first
category in separating and classifying
angiosperms angiosperms are either
monocots or die cuts so this
characteristic is only true for
angiosperms this does not apply to
gymnosperms it does not apply to Moss
and it does not apply to ferns
so this monocot and dicot one embryonic
leaf and two embryonic leaves that only
applies to angiosperms
and so in this table you're gonna see
there's really five characteristics
which we can use to determine whether or
not a plant is a monocot or a dicot of
the five - I think are just more key
because they're simpler like this first
picture says and this goes back to what
we just mentioned the moment ago the
monocot has one embryonic leaf as now as
an embryo and a dicot embryo has two
embryonic leaves but there's a kind of a
simpler way and that's the this key
point that's about to be unveiled if you
just pluck off a leaf and look at the
veins of the leaf you can usually have
your answer if the plant is a monocot or
a dicot notice in the monocot all the
veins of the leaf run parallel in one
direction
that's a monocot but at the bottom the
veins branch out in a net-like formation
that's a dicot a third characteristic
that you can use to identify monocot and
dicot book at the bottom we mentioned
that angiosperms are vascular plants
look at the bottom in a dicot the
vascular bundles are arranged in a ring
in a monocot they're not now again
there's easier ways to figure out
monocot and dicot besides breaking open
the stem you can just pluck off a leaf
that's a really easy way to do it here's
another a fourth way to turn to
determine monocot versus dicot but again
you know if you have a tree are you
gonna uproot the tree just to look at
its roots to see if it's monocot or a
dicot if it's a dicot you see it's got
that one big gigantic tap root in the
middle and then all these tiny branches
coming off of the tap root so there's
easier ways to do this again pluck a
leaf off of it and if the veins are
parallel you got a monocot if they are
net like you got a die cut there's
another key point though besides the
leaf veins this is the last one look at
the flower parts if you count the petals
or count the sepals eventually count the
male parts called the stamen flower
parts if they are in multiples of 3 that
would be a
okay but if they're in multiples of four
or five that would be a dicot now one
question that comes up every year is
well what if it's a multi order if
there's 12 sepals and petals 12 is a
multiple of 3 and 12 is a multiple of 4
how do you know well you you have to
look some at something else for
information if it has 12 flower parts
the women look at the leaves do the
veins run parallel or are the veins
net-like so again of these five I would
say focus on the leaf veins and focus on
the flowers of these five these those
two are kind of the more obvious ones to
look at
and so here's just a few practice
practice examples this is the leaf and
the flower of an apple tree the leaf
shows net like veins and one two three
four five petals this is a die cut
another flower with six petals actually
three petals and three sepals but we'll
talk about petals and sepals in a little
bit this is again six is a multiple of
three
here we have three petals you can see
the the yellow male stamen in the middle
there's six of them
that's a multiple of three and if you
look at the leaf in the background the
leaves in the background you can see the
veins all run parallel that's a monocot
if you count up the flower petals again
five petals that's multiple of five
dicot I hope this is getting pretty
straightforward
here's some here's a couple leaves here
and see all the veins run parallel so
there's your mom okay so this is pretty
straight
as long as you remember those basic
rules here we have again veins running
parallel on this leaf this leaf monocot
because the veins run parallel
and lastly here we have the veins or
branched out net like and so this is a
dicot so keep in mind monocots and
dicots those are terms that only apply
to angiosperms
and so when it comes to angiosperms
there are three lifestyle or life cycle
patterns lifespans sorry there are three
lifespans that we've noticed three
patterns for how long they live and the
first pattern are plants that only live
one year and we call these annual plants
now a lot has to happen in order for
this thing to to reproduce all in one
season so perhaps the seed in early
spring will germinate the seeds starts
to grow the plant will then do all of
its growth during the summer months but
then near the fall and autumn it'll
produce a flower the flower will produce
a seed the end inside the see I said
that wrong it'll produce a flower the
flower will produce a fruit and inside
the fruit you will find seeds and
eventually later on as the weather gets
colder the plant will die and so all
that has to happen in one year now it's
okay that the plant dies because notice
how it makes seeds the seeds left behind
will grow the next year so angiosperms
that fall into this annual category here
well they're obviously not going to be
large trees trees don't grow to their
full height in one year so this would be
small flowers right here
another lifespan pattern that I want to
mention some and some angiosperms fall
into what's called a biennial pattern
they live for two years so here we have
a timeline showing two years here so
maybe in the early spring a seed will
germinate again it just means that it
starts to grow during the summer months
the plant gets bigger and bigger and
bigger then during the winter time the
plant will go into a dormant state where
it's too cold to grow and not enough
moisture so it'll become dormant that'll
carry over that will carry over into the
second year and once it warms up in the
springtime the plant will continue to
grow get bigger and bigger and bigger
and then in the fall and autumn of the
second year it will produce flowers the
flowers will produce a fruit and inside
the fruit you'll find seeds and then
again in the wintertime the plant will
die not a big deal though because the
seeds that are left behind will grow the
next year so some some angiosperms
follow this by any old pattern
and the third pattern
I want to mention are called perennials
they live for more than two years and so
here's a timeline that's gonna show five
years I'm not insinuating that all
perennials live five years okay I just
wanted to kind of go over the basic
pattern here so let's say that in the
first year the seed germinates and
starts to grow the plant gets bigger and
bigger during the summer months and then
during the winter just like we saw a
moment ago the plant enters a dormant
state that carries over into year number
two and then when the weather warms up
the plant will grow some more but the
plants not mature enough yet to produce
a flower and fruit and seeds it needs to
grow more but now that winter is rolled
around it will go dormant again and so
that'll carry over into the third year
and then as it warms up the plant will
grow bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and so in this little animation
here were only three years into the
process and in this animation eventually
it says that the plant will grow flowers
the flowers will produce fruit and
inside the fruit you'll find seeds this
does not always happen in the third year
I'm just using this as a general
guideline here some in some angiosperms
that are perennials this might take ten
years this might take fifteen years it
might take twenty years it depends on
the species but then once winter rolls
around the plant will go dormant that
will continue into the fourth year into
the fifth year the plant will grow some
more and as long as it's got the
available resources once it's hit
adulthood age it can produce more
flowers more fruit more seeds go dormant
in the winter and then next spring start
growing some more produce flower which
produce fruits which produce inside the
fruit you'll find seeds and eventually
the flower is gonna tear the plant is
gonna die now again I'm not insinuating
that this happens on a five-year
timeline here I just used this as a
general guideline
you
so let's look at the actual flowers and
their parts so here we have some flowers
they don't look very pretty at you're
certainly not going to give a bouquet of
these to your sweetheart but a flower is
the reproductive structure of
angiosperms it's how they make more of
themselves it's how they pass their
genes on from one generation to the next
so what we're gonna first see are the
outer protective leaves of a flower we
call these sepals
well now once the seat will start to
peel back and here's a great picture of
it once the seat will start to peel back
we have an inner ring of leaves that are
often brightly colored again to attract
pollinators
so once the sepals spread open the
petals are revealed now if we were to
peel back the sepals and peel back the
petals we would eventually come to the
actual male and female organs that are
found on the inside and if we take a
look at a flower from above you might
see something like this this is not the
exact same species that we just looked
at it's just a flower with Clare an
obvious male and female parts we'll talk
about how I know which one of this is
these is the female and which one is the
male in just a moment but now we can see
the actual the actual reproductive
organs that are inside of flowers so
let's go into this with more detail
so let's first of all first of all focus
our attention ladies first on the female
part of the plant and so if we look at
this picture right here the innermost
portion of this flower is the female
part called the carpel we'll start at
the bottom and we'll work our way up at
the bottom of the flow of the at the
base of this flower we have what's
called an ovary a round base at the
bottom inside of that ovary we see an
object labeled as the ovule that's where
eventually we're going to see the egg
will form in this picture there are
eight ovules inside of that one ovary
so the ovary is here our female
gametophyte because of tabloid and
notice how the word style just popped up
on to the picture notice how there's a
long slender stalk that reaches high
into the high up this is a [ __ ] a long
slender stalk and we call this thing the
style and you'll see its purpose in just
a moment because on top of the style we
have an object called the stigma the
stigma is sticky and we'll touch on that
in just a moment so if we know that this
that a flower is the reproductive
structure in order to reproduce the
female part the carpel needs to catch
pollen and so I hope you can imagine
what what the purpose of the style is if
the stigma is elevated high into the air
better chance of pollen landing on the
stigma and I hope you can figure out the
benefit of the stigma being sticky
if the style elevates the stigma and the
stigma is sticky there's a much greater
chance that pollen will actually land on
it at that case we would have
pollination so let's look at the male
structures the male structures are
called the stamen and they typically
surround the female part again the
female part is called the carpel in this
picture we can actually see
five different mail structures that are
surrounding the female carpal the mail
structures over are called stamen we'll
start at the bottom and work our way up
there is a long slender stalk that
elevates the male part this long slender
stalk is called a filament on top of the
filament we find an object called an
anther and in this picture you can see
actually five different anthers what the
anthers do is they produce pollen and so
eventually the pollen will be released
into the air and perhaps the pollen will
land on its own stigma or maybe the
stigma of a neighbor but when the
anthers produce pollen pollen is the
male gametophyte because pollen is
haploid so what's going to this process
a little more in detail
here we have a close-up picture of male
and female parts again the female part
typically in the middle the male part on
the outside by the way if I do a quick
count I can count 1 2 3 4 5 6 male parts
multiple of 6 is this a monocot or a
dicot I'm not going to tell you look it
up if you don't remember multiple of 6
here is the male and female parts of a
lily we see the purple female part in
the middle and surrounding the purple
female part we find 1 2 3 4 5 6 male
parts again multiple of 6 is this a
monocot or a dicot and this is a great
picture by the way of the female stigma
the purple part on top great picture you
can see see it really well here and that
purple stigma is supported high in the
air by that green slender object called
the style here we have another example
of the male and female parts the female
part by the way you might also hear
called the pistil if you notice on our
notes I called it the carpel now it says
pistol you kind of hear both of these
terms used and here we have again one
last example now I'm not gonna ask you
to count how many male parts are there
to try to figure out if this is a
monocot or a dicot remember you can also
just look at the leaves do the veins run
parallel or are they net like to figure
out if it's monocot or a dicot
so if if flowers have both male and
female parts are they able to fertilize
themselves the answer to that question
is yes watch our animation
if pollen from its own anther lands on
its own stigma well we could proceed
with the pollination and so yes this is
called self pollination and will go into
the pollination process more in just a
moment
course we might also see
cross-pollination where pollen from the
flower on the left lands on the stigma
to the right and so this would be called
cross-pollination
so let's go into a little more detail
let's focus on the male anthers let's
zoom I'm into one of those anthers right
there
so the anthers as we said a moment ago
create eventually create Polland well
before we get to that part that pollen
let's turn back the steps and let's go
through this in a little more detail
earlier in the school year we learned
that meiosis creates four cells at a
time and that those cells are haploid so
notice in the picture we have a diploid
cell in the middle going through the
process of meiosis creating four
microspores those microspores are the
male gametophyte s' they're haploid and
in each of those cells there's one
nucleus but watch the picture those
cells the nucleus of those cells will
divide so those one cells when the
nucleus divide that one cell will now
have two nuclei and look at all four of
those cells each have two nuclei in them
one of those nuclei one nucleus like
it's labeled will form what's called a
pollen tube which will be more important
in a few moments the other nucleus will
divide again into two more so you got
the one nucleus that forms the pollen
tube and now you got two more nuclei
that are created for a total of three
well why are there three nuclei we just
said one will form the pollen tube one
of them is gonna fertilize the egg to
then create a zygote and the other one
is gonna make what's called an endosperm
and we'll talk more about the end of
sperm in a little bit I just want to
throw these or throw this word out there
so when we get to it in a few moments in
a few minutes you know you'll see the
purpose of it so I know it's a lot of
cell divisions going on in here but this
is the the detailed process of what
takes place in the male anthers the
female process is actually a little more
kind
phlex than this so but once the pollen
grains are created notice how at meiosis
makes four microspores they're not
pollen yet they're not pollen until the
until the next process happens and they
divide again
so once the pollen is created
one
Pollan is created the pollen is released
sometimes pollen is released into the
air sometimes pollen is transferred by
insects by Birds
in this animation the pollen was
transferred by the air
and so we'll we'll come back to that
pollen floating around in the air in
just a moment but let's look at what
happens with the female process so here
we have a great picture showing the
difference between the ovary and an
ovule the ovary is the overall base of
this flower and inside of the ovary if I
were to ask you how many of you all's
are there you can see that there are six
what we're gonna do we're gonna zoom
into one of those ovules and pay
attention as to what's happening in one
of them so we know that meiosis anytime
reproduction is involved you should know
meiosis is involved and that the cells
created will be haploid so if we follow
this picture that says meiosis makes
four megaspores so here we have one cell
in purple but it's gonna divide by
meiosis to make four cells you see how
they're labeled megaspores but look it
says like it says in my notes of those
four cells only one of them are gonna
survive watch this next picture in this
next picture you see there are four
purple cells labeled a drawn but three
of them are labeled degenerating that
means that they're gonna die they're
gonna wear away so four cells are made
but only one will survive well let's
focus on that one that survives three
the dies we don't care about anymore
let's focus on the one that survives
okay the one that survives has one
nucleus but that one nucleus will divide
in the two the two nuclei will divide in
the four the four nuclei will divide
into eight this one cell you notice how
that one cell in purple look how the
picture changed that one sound purple
has grown and now it's got eight smaller
circles in it those are the eight nuclei
in that one surviving megaspore well why
are there eight nuclei well let's see
what happens with these eight nuclei one
of those eight will combine with a sperm
to make as
two of them are gonna form an object
called the embryo sac and we'll see why
that's relevant in a little bit and what
about the other five the other five
disintegrate and degenerate and die that
nothing happens of them so of those
eight nuclei only three survived and so
as we look at the final step of this
picture here we can see that two of the
nuclei in the middle have formed are
going to form an object called an embryo
sac one of the nuclei is going to form
an egg cell and the other five that
aren't labeled those are the five that
are going to die
let's actually remember a moment ago we
saw pollen blowing off of the male to
male stamen let's see what happens next
so here's our pollen grain it just
landed on the stigma notice how there
are three black dots well if you
remember why are the three black dots
because in each pen there are three
nuclei
so there are three nuclei in this pollen
grain and as we said one of them is
gonna form a pollen tube watch the
animation one of them is gonna form a
pollen tube which will go all the way
down into the ovary and in a moment two
nuclei are gonna transfer the other two
are gonna transfer through that tube
now how many here's a reminder in the in
an ovule there's already three nuclei
member eight nuclei were created in the
female ovule but of the eight five died
one is gonna form an egg two of them are
gonna form the embryo sac there's
already three nuclei in there but when
the three nuclei that are already in the
ovule
when when the two nuclei in this pollen
travel down the pollen tube that brings
us to a total of five so there's five
nuclei in that ah've you will now three
from the female two from the male this
leads to a process called double
fertilization the reason it's called
double fertilization is because to two
sperm cells two sperm cell nuclei
traveled down that pollen tube and so
two fertilization events are going to
happen in the first fertile each
fertilization event one nucleus from the
sperm will combine with one nucleus from
the egg that creates a zygote well
remember what about the other nuclei the
other nuclei from the sperm will combine
with the two nuclei from the egg one
plus two adds up to three nuclei fuse
together if uses together and forms an
embryo sac and something called an
endosperm the endosperm will be the
nutrition that the zygote and embryo
will eventually feed off of until the
seed cracks open and it can do
photosynthesis
you
you
so after fertilization the sperm and the
egg have have created a zygote that
ovule will harden into a seed and so in
this ovary I've only drawn one seed in
reality there might be more than one
seed I've just drawn one in this
animation but the ovule will harden into
a seed
the ovary the base of this flower is
gonna grow into a fleshy fruit the rest
of the flower is gonna simply die so
here we go the rest of the flower is
dying and the ovary will grow into a
fleshy fruit inside of that fruit there
are seeds now though
eventually the Apple will ripen and it
will get heavy and just fall to the
ground once the apples on the ground of
course it can be food for animals
animals such as pigs such as horses and
so the in this case a pig comes and eats
the Apple
and so like it says the fruit will be
digested but the seeds will pass through
the digestive system of a pig so in this
case the apple is eaten you can see it's
slowly wearing away and dissolving it's
being digested but look at how there are
seeds in the digestive system of this
pig eventually those seeds are going to
come out the other end and those seeds
when they come out the other end are in
a big pile of fertilizer of feces of
poop and so this will actually help the
seeds in their growth
you
and so after a little bit of time a
seedling will begin to grow a young
sporophyte will begin to grow and after
if all goes according to plan after many
many many many years if not decades you
have an adult tree an adult sporophyte
that produces flowers to restart the
life cycle so in general that's a
rundown of the life cycle of angiosperms
and some of their characteristics here
is just a wonderful diagram that I found
that helps to summarize what we
mentioned earlier so if you want to look
at this diagram pause it and and it
makes good review if you have any
questions by all means please come on
into my office or come into my classroom
and I'd be happy to discuss angiosperms
or any other questions you might have